my theory is basically buy a camera and
start filming
[Music]
I mean I didn't go to film school I
didn't pick up books and start learning
I just went and started doing
filmmaker Brian Smith has been in an
adventure longer than he's been a
filmmaker he's part of a growing number
internet savvy adventures who represent
the nexus of storytelling and
athleticism for me the early days of
filmmaking grew out of a passion for
kayaking not really a passion for
filming
Brennan's friends were pioneering new
kayaking descents on a Pacific Northwest
steep creeks every weekend produced
adventures and misadventures like
[Music]
it was about going out in the woods with
a group of friends and having fun and
then trying to share that story with
everyone else
Brian bought a small camera and started
documenting their trips being able to
paddle down the river and being able to
carry a camera with you you actually
have a pretty unique equation really
early on I realized that the filmmaking
part of it was gonna offer just as much
adventure as the adventuring he says
it's good
[Music]
over the course of six years Brian's
small camcorder has become a
state-of-the-art camera he's travelling
the globe filming for National
Geographic
but the grassroots spirit has remained
the camera for me is that tool to keep
pushing me into adventure
[Music]
there's no separation at all between the
adventure and the filmmaking
it's all happening simultaneously one
second you're thinking about the camera
the next you're thinking about your
footing
[Music]
but there's a big suffering coefficient
is what I call it it could be your legs
going numb and harness your hands
freezing off and a snowstorm in the
summer of 2010 Smith embarked on his
biggest challenge yet it would be the
team of kayakers
on a series of first ascents and rushes
come track a peninsula for me when I
first started filmmaking I had no idea
that four years later I would be going
to come chaka far eastern Russia filming
for National Geographic I mean it was a
dream come true one thing that's really
interesting with camera here is that
people always have this like attachment
to it like oh it's precious we had to
kind of throw that out the window it was
like we were paddling class five rivers
big waterfalls with expensive cameras
right between our legs and at any moment
we could have swum and lost the camera
gear
the key to any adventure whether it's
kayaking or filmmaking is it the outcome
is unknown right up until the end
[Music]
you